pierre laurent votre action d'abord à
cet accord entre les insoumis et les
écologistes c'est une bonne chose moi je
pense que c'est une très bonne nouvelle
et nous sommes en route vers un accord
de toute la gauche et les communistes
vont faire partie de cet accord-cadre au
concept après midi à 14 heures je pense
que les conditions sont en train d'être
rayée d'être créé pour aller vers un
accord de tout le monde et je m'en
félicite
d'accord avec les communistes la france
en son miroir d'accord avec les
communistes et je présidais la réunion
du conseil national samedi
tout le monde s'est exprimé en faveur
d'un accord et personne parce que j'ai
entendu circuler une personne n'a parlé
de rupture ou je ne sais quoi d'ailleurs
nous étions prêts nous à nous réunir
hier bons essais il ça a commencé avec
les verts ça continue avec nous
aujourd'hui je crois avec les
socialistes nous allons vers un accord
et je crois en accordant globale et
c'est une très bonne nouvelle parce que
les gens ne veulent pas je le répète les
gens n'ont pas voulu de marine le pen
ils ne veulent pas des réformes
antisociales d'emmanuel macro donc je
crois qu'une majorité qui correspond à
ses attentes sociales elle est possible
dans le pays et il faut absolument ancré
en créer les conditions j'ai lu l'accord
signé avec les verts cette nuit tout ce
qu'il ya dans la déclaration commune
entre et les filles est écrit dans le
programme que nous très fendue à
l'élection présidentielle nous n'avons
aucun problème avec toutes ces mesures
là puisqu'elle figure tout quasiment et
même certaines pour ce qui nous concerne
qui vont plus loin d'ailleurs je pense
qu'avec la france insoumise on peut on
peut en dire plus encore que la france
soumise l'on a dit en commun avec les
verts donc je pense que les conditions
sont créées pour un accord on va revenir
sur le sur le fond avec alex mai
vous vous souhaiter un accord vous dites
il y aura un accord ça a été actée au
sein des instances du parti de mise est
ce que c'est quand même pas un peu
bizarre c'est vous qui avez voulu y
aller seule à la présidentielle sans
accord notamment avec la france
insoumise et la d'acter un accord pour
des législatives alors vous avez un
ancrage l'hiver l'alliance a raison
c'est un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle et maintenant il ya un
accord pour les législatives les
communistes ont présenté un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle il va y avoir
un accord pour les élections
législatives
je rappelle que quand nous avons décidé
d'avoir un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
nous avons pris la décision à la
conférence nationale du parti communiste
que nous travaillerons un pacte commun
pour les législatives c'est ce qui est
en train de se faire et c'est ce qui va
permettre et tout ce qui s'est passé
depuis et notamment depuis le résultat
du premier tour montre qu'il faut aller
vers ça alors il ya des choses à régler
notamment vous l'avez dit en ce qui nous
concerne faut vérifier que l'accord
puisque c'est jean luc mélenchon dit
chacun aura un groupe dans l'effort de
conquête global nous voulons vérifier
que les conditions que nous ayons à un
groupe dont 15 députés soient réunies
mais une fois que nous allons vérifier
ça et que sur le fond nous allons mettre
sur le papier ce qui nous est commun
comme nous le proposons depuis la
semaine dernière eh ben je crois que les
conditions seront réunies dans l'accord
justement
[Musique]